cet art on a fait cette fête t'es
sérieux le fait comme à l'époque avait
tous nos potes comme avant on commence
par qui a d'abord à nous fournissons le
cavalier de la ligne complètement taré
kuijken
bonjour c'est nico qui vous a ramené
complètement bourré alors qu'il n'avait
pas son permis de conduire c'est
vraiment une belle bande retenait si
maintenant vous me dégoûtez lady elle
avait envie de vomir
d'accord il ya peut-être un peu du mien
mais décousu dessus servent weck a
continué arrêter de se voir
pardon a fait ces tests c'est sérieux
une fête comme à l'époque avec tous les
potes comme avant et comment ce parc et
géraldine fragonard frago la chevasse il
paraît qu'elle portait des pilotes
comestibles dont elle se tartiner la
touffe avec le nutella n'importe quoi
cette légende mais promet ce choix là ça
passera de le tripler la coucou bravo
qu'est ce que tu fais là c'est pas vrai
parce que nous avons dit bouffon
c'est partant on l'a fait c'était très
sérieux le fait comme à l'époque avec
tous nos potes comme avant vincent lui
une légende ce mec-là un aspirateur à
gonzesses et le bond de 11 verges
toutes les finales en lan ou des buts
maliens au dos on va les faire une offre
tu pourras pas refusé l offre non je
parle je dis ça comme ça c'est mal pic
du pin et concrètement du coup qu'il s'y
colla mais a pas d'offre c'est une
réplique du parrain je peux dire je vais
lui faire une offre qui pourra pas le
refuge est et on va lui dire sa justice
qu'il défère ici en fait il a mis qui
est tout noir n'en était qu'au sud
allez y à ça me fait plaisir de vous
voir